the jurgen experience i
i was brought up i was brought mormon
really so i was brought more sam was
mormon well my family's mormon
were all excommunicated what happened my
dad got us all taken out of the thing so
it was just like we were like deep we
were deep
and then when we moved provinces the
church wasn't good
here in ontario so in nova scotia
big big fellowship we mormon world
you know then what my dad was like a
high deacon or whatever the [ __ ] it was
or like
we we always like sat next to like the
bishops family like front row [ __ ]
because it's all like
the families whoever's like up on the
stage or whatever like the family sit in
the front rows and [ __ ]
and so then when we moved to ontario
i [ __ ] you know uh
like when we were about 12 or 13 right
around like that time when we started
all of a sudden doing like drugs and
drinking
is when we stopped going to the church
because that's maybe a part of it too
right
where like we were like i never had a
coca-cola i never saw a pg
rated movie we only watched g-rated
really
i never saw the simpsons until i was you
know like things like that like we were
allowed
so once you got excommunicated from the
church they just well
we took ourselves my dad i don't know if
ex communicates the right word left the
church we when we left the church but
because they have so much information on
you
and your family like [ __ ] family tree
stuff
like it takes a long time to actually
get your like your [ __ ] out of there
what do you mean
like uh you're in for like i think they
just have like a lot of information on
you
and your families and they do a lot of
ancestral stuff right so i think they do
like a lot of
and you you know the pen you got to give
all like even like i would get two
dollars a week
for my allowance and i'd have to give 10
percent to the church
so we would all be my brothers we would
have to take our nickels
or whatever our dimes and we'd have to
give our our 10
to the church really yeah yeah so that
was training like just saying like that
training of like giving the church the
money from day one
and all that kind of [ __ ] so it was just
like and then you know my parents are
like
they were young and it's great they were
like the the young
the young couple that got knocked on and
my dad was like come on in like drink
like you want a beer and and all of a
sudden my dad was just like
and it was one of those things where i'm
like why you know we were so
like you like when i found that out
later on i was like you literally just
like somebody
knocked on you let a missionary in here
you know like where it's like so funny
how old were you when you were asking
them that question like like later like
in my 20s
yeah like when i had like some balls to
like you know dads are so scary
so i was just like you know like huh
yeah just why you're asking him why
yeah just like some quite like where i
was just like you know like he would
come visit me in college
we'd go have like lunch you know my dad
would drive up to the city and you know
having those father-son kind of
conversations like hey like this was
kind of crazy back then they're like why
was this or like
you know like why why you know why were
we never allowed to like sleep over at
other kids houses or like
you know like things like little small
things that i don't think are
you know crazy but i think it's
definitely like one of those things that
like
you know never having like a coca-cola
and then all of a sudden i'm like doing
acid
you know i'm all gas you know like it's
just like i was like
oh cool we're not mormons anymore let's
do some blotter acids sometimes that's
what triggers it right it's the
repression
there's so much repression and then all
sudden they take the
reins off you well and the idea of
heaven just like at a young age
i strongly felt like there was no heaven
and i strongly felt
i didn't believe it from a young age
because i also and
there's three levels of heaven in the
mormon in the mormon or in the book of
mormon right there's like the celestial
the [ __ ] whatever and whatever
so i was just like this does have three
levels of heaven there's like three
levels of heaven so there's tears
there's tears right so the thing that i
was i was a klepto
as a kid i would walk into like you know
a little store and like
grab a little thing like i remember i
stole a jackknife once from like this
like
you know hardware store like i would
just like take things you know a little
klepto
and in my head at a very young age i was
like i'm never going to be
eternal with my parents at a very young
age i was like my parents are like you
know they did the whole thing with the
underwear and they're married forever
and like
[ __ ] underwear is wild daddy i think
they had to give it back or they had to
get rid of it i don't [ __ ] know
i don't know let's facetime steve and be
like what the [ __ ] did you have to give
the underwear back
i still don't understand like they have
information on you like why does that
make it hard to leave because they tell
you hey we know things about you
like no i don't think it's like weird
like that kind of stuff i just think
our [ __ ] out to be like stricken of the
books
right so you don't have to pay them
every week can you well you don't have
to pence or just like you or i think
it's called pence but i think it's like
once again there's probably a lot of
mormons watching this that are being
like manny doesn't know [ __ ] and i don't
know [ __ ] okay
i don't know [ __ ] i just lived it right
but i just think it it is
um i remember it was just one of those
things where
i remember my dad and my sister it was
crazy
because she had a child out of wedlock
she's gonna love that i say this but she
had like a child out of wedlock
and so that was like a thing where i
think it was like i don't even know i
think there was like a thing where she
got like a piece of paper saying she had
to go in front of like a tribunal
oh boy and like you know explain herself
or she was getting or
maybe she was getting excrement i still
forget it's kind of fuzzy
but i think it was like one of those
things where i remember when the
missionaries showed up
and it was almost like they served her
like papers or some [ __ ] and i remember
my older brother almost like beat the
[ __ ]
out of these missionaries it was like
get the [ __ ] out of you know one of
those kind of things like get off our
porch get the [ __ ] out of here
serving you papers you violated i don't
know
like that's the thing is like i don't
like a lot of uh well that is the
wackiest religion
it's the wackiest right yeah i know of
course i'm a part of it it's like
other than scientology i was baptized
it's the wackiest one it's the wackiest
one right right right they know the guy
who made it up and he was like
we used to go we used to go to the hill
where he found the book of mormon and
they used to redo the event and we would
visit
the jail where he was like murdered how
old was he
when they killed him in his 20s that's
in that wild
john smith right john smith um
joseph joseph smith he invented it when
he was 14 years old
let's go that's incredible that's like
now that's like
a tick-tocker you know everyone just
follows tick-tock same [ __ ]
well i just can't imagine a 14 year old
that's not full of [ __ ]
yeah you know like a 14 year old tells
you a story like that and everybody's
like wow
he's like let's go you've met angels
what are they like they were beautiful
you have golden tablets i love a golden
tablet
with the last work of jesus jesus
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience